[Musica]
buon per tutti i ragazzi di the backs mi
hanno chiesto di venire a parlarvi di
democrazia digitale
ebbene mi presento sono porfirio
rubirosa mi sono un cantautore dadaista
le mie canzoni si basano sul paradosso
ebbene io oggi vi darò prova di un
paradosso
oggi vi dimostrerò con metodo
scientifico galileiano con prove
inoppugnabili che una bella sana
vigorosa e financo virile dittatura
costituisce la base per la fioritura non
solo della democrazia ma dell'universale
concetto di libertà potremmo persino
inventarci uno slogan dittatura per una
democrazia duratura
lo so fa ridere ma è un'idea che ho fin
da piccolo fin da quando ero bambino mio
padre era un appassionato di auto e di
donne o forse era un appassionato di
donne e credeva che le auto fossero in
mezzo migliore per coltivare la sua
passione di lumacone fatto sta che
cambiava l'auto ogni anno in famiglia
non eravamo poveri ma nemmeno ricchi e
quindi le auto doveva gioco forza
comperarle usate insomma comunque il
tutto così intaccava i fondi a
disposizione della famiglia fuori una
alfa romeo quasi nuova dentro un ariston
quasi da buttare
mio padre era molto molto furbo riusciva
a farti credere che comperando le auto
usate e non abbatteva la svalutazione
del nuovo
e cambiandole spesso il valore dell'auto
non non cambiava e in più ti faceva
anche credere che partecipano
attivamente alla scelta dell'auto tutte
balle tutte balle
allora succedeva così arrivava a casa ed
esordiva con un bel è arrivata l'ora di
cambiare l'auto di famiglia
e siccome voi fate parte della famiglia
è giusto che anche voi di chat e la
vostra allora pativo io ed entusiasta
proponeva una bella mercedes mia madre
timidamente ci provava con una bmw mio
padre marziale per per l'audi seguivano
giorni e giorni di valutazione sui pro e
contro mercedes bmw audi e alla fine
vediamo se indovinate alla fine qual era
l'auto che veniva scelta
l'audi quella scelta da mio padre ogni
anno tutti gli anni la stessa cosa
io ci provavo entusiasta mia mamma
diceva la sua e poi alla fine l'alto
scelta era sempre quella di mio padre
e così dopo pochi giorni ci ritrovavamo
fuori una bella audi 90 color sabbia
giuro una volta ha comperato un audi
color sabbia
allora al di là delle stravaganze e
cromatiche questo racconto che vi ho
fatto
e a mio parere molto utile per farci
capire meglio i concetti di democrazia
di rappresentatività e di partecipazione
noi siamo abituati a pensare che la
democrazia sia il governo del popolo
lo certifica il vocabolario ma
soprattutto ci hanno insegnato che il
bello della democrazia è che tutti sono
rappresentati all'interno della
democrazia tutte le categorie ci sono i
conservatori ci sono i liberali
c'è qualche radicale ci sono tutte le
minoranze in democrazia pensate c'è
spazio persino per gli omofobi persino
per gli omofobi perfino per i xenofobi
insomma c'è spazio per tutti ea noi
diciamo siamo tranquilli perché vivendo
in questa democrazia in cui c'è la
massima rappresentatività
riteniamo di poter partecipare al
processo democratico meglio ancora se
magari facendolo comodamente seduti da
casa con un click
ma siamo proprio sicuri che sia così
siamo certi che le cose funzionano così
allora facciamo così proviamo a fare un
esperimento ci state
bene allora al mio tre
dovette pronunciare attenzione la martin
della vostra auto non il modello mi
raccomando è solo la marca altre pronti
ben 123 non è che ci ho capito
moltissimo ma non fosse una questione
che da siete partiti tutti a tempo e
magari non avete una tela voce bella
stentorea ci riproviamo da un'altra
volta però questa quella era la prova
adesso facciamo la bene dai altre solo
la marca non il modello pronti 123
allora cerchiamo di capirci mi
confermate che siete seduti in poltrona
mi confermate che la poltrona è
sufficientemente comoda potete
confermarmi che al mio tre
voi avete pronunciato con voce stentorea
il modello non la marca e non il modello
della vostra auto e potete confermarmi
che ciò nonostante non si è capito se
c'erano bmw se c'erano mercedes e
c'erano audis
lo sapevi dalle mail allora siete una
volta into the water l'altra volta era
un pronto clientela si sapeva 7000 metri
ci siamo mandati quale numero uno stack
ha pure hanno progetti le lucine
cyberbike misure si ok però in anticipo
il facciamo il direttore che almeno
possiamo fargli finire al talk media lo
tagliamo il problema i fronti non è che
ho detto per fare pubblicità lo tagliamo
dopo non preoccupare precise non si può
dire sì preferirei fare grazie ma non
posso continuare a cioè non posso fumare
l'affaccio infatti rare e lo facciamo
tirare lo tagliamo e in qualche modo
facciamo dai vai pure avanti grazie
allora quello che avete appena visto è
un esempio concreto dei concetti di
democrazia di dittatura e di
partecipazione
in questo senso il drugo arculeo mio
compagno di mille incursioni dadaiste i
ragazzi di ted e matteo ci hanno dato
una mano per tutta una messinscena
forse qualcuno l'ha capito forse non lo
avete capito ma non ha importanza
quello che è importante che quello che
voi avete appena visto ci ha dato più di
mille parole
un esempio concreto di alcune dinamiche
abbiamo capito che esprimere la propria
opinione rimanendo seduti in poltrona ha
un'utilità relativa voi avete detto è
pronunciato la marca della vostra auto
chi lo ha sentito quasi nessuno sono
quelli che erano attorno a voi ma nel
marasma complessivo delle informazioni
quella la vostra partecipazione non è
arrivata per davvero
voi avete avuto una illusione di libertà
effimera mente confermata dalle persone
che vi circondano ma che nell'economia
complessiva in questa narrazione liquida
si disperde e proprio è talmente liquida
che a un certo punto si asciuga ricorda
molto quelle processioni che a volte si
vedono camminare e per i marciapiedi di
new york in cui un piccolo gruppo
sparuto di persone manifestano per i
motivi più disparati gli altri astanti
li guardano incuriositi e dopo poco
riprendono la loro attività come nulla
fosse
giorgio gaber direbbe che quei
manifestanti non sono realmente liberi
ma stanno invece facendo quello che la
libertà vuole che loro facciano ma vi
faccio un altro esempio il drugo arculeo
quando abbiamo fatto la consultazione
per le marche di auto nella prima
consultazione ha urlato niente marche
chi lo ha sentito nessuno nella seconda
consultazione assieme a voi
lui ha urlato basta di blocco anche in
questo caso nessuno lo ha sentito
solamente quando lui è arrivato qui le
cose sono veramente cambiate solamente
quando ha messo in campo una reale
azione le cose sono cambiate potremmo
dire che in epoca di democrazia digitale
più di migliore
quindi persone comodamente sedute in
poltrona
ne vale di più una sola che si alza ed è
in grado di staccare la spina che
alimenta il server
naturalmente io non sto dicendo che il
drugo scuro quando è arrivato qua avesse
un atteggiamento condivisibile è stato
un dittatore il suo atteggiamento è
stato dispotico è stato deprecabile e
quindi non è questo il punto ma la cosa
bella è che dopo di questo noi a un
certo punto ci siamo coalizzati voi vi
siete coalizzati insieme per rovesciare
la situazione precedente cioè insieme
avete creato un gruppo di pensiero
compatto per farlo però avete dovuto
avere bisogno di un nemico comune
e quel nemico comune che può essere di
volta in volta un dittatore può essere
il terrorismo può essere la pandemia è
quello che ci unisce
bertrand russell in autorità ed
individuo scrive che quando siamo
sull'autobus la persona che è seduta
accanto a noi per noi non significa
nulla ma se quell'autobus si trova sotto
un bombardamento quella persona accanto
a noi diventa nostro fratello
allora se noi capiamo questa dinamica se
noi siamo in grado di capire che è lo
stimolo quello che ci fa passare dall
illusione di azione all'azione allora
possiamo fare a meno di quello stimolo e
agire direttamente ma per farlo dobbiamo
imparare a rimettere al centro una cosa
che ormai sta scomparendo ed è il
concetto di fatica la fatica è un
concetto che sta scomparendo perché la
tecnologia come primo nemico giurato a
la fatica perché la tecnologia ha
bisogno di portare nelle nostre vite
la comodità ma dobbiamo imparare a fare
una grande distinzione che è la
distinzione tra comodità e benessere non
sempre ciò che è comodo costituisce
anche un benessere e quindi dobbiamo
superare questa differenza tra azione e
illusione di azione io non sto dicendo
attenzione che la tecnologia sia sempre
sbagliata ma dobbiamo distinguere tra
una tecnologia
la buona e una tecnologia cattiva
dobbiamo capire che non salveremo la
democrazia con un click
così come non salveremo il pianeta non
stampando le e mail che ci mandano o
facendo la raccolta differenziata questo
è tutto
e tutta comunicazione a tutto talking
emozionale serve per farci credere di
stare facendo qualche cosa ma in realtà
non stiamo facendo assolutamente nulla
questo e talking emozionale che tolta
l'enfasi non rimane nulla circa 100 anni
fa qualcuno disse il concetto di libertà
non è assoluto perché nulla nella vita
mia di assoluto la libertà non è un
diritto e un dovere non è un'elargizione
è una conquista non è un uguaglianza è
un privilegio
il concetto di libertà muta col passare
del tempo
vedete vi siete fatti fregare un'altra
volta avete appena applaudito a un
concetto quello di libertà relativa
propugnato da benito mussolini
all'indomani del delitto matteotti la
libertà non è mai un concetto relativo
la libertà è sempre un concetto assoluto